ليس مقياس ريختر وحده مؤشرا على فداحه
الزلازل واثارها التدميريه هناك عوامل
اخرى يشير اليها الخبراء تساهم في تحديد
نسبه الخسائر البشريه والماديه لزلزال
بعينه بعض الزلازل مثلا جاوزت ثمان درجات
دون ان تعلق في الذاكره لعدم وجود خسائر
تقريبا كزلزال الاسكا صيف
2011 الذي وقع على بعد اكثر من 100 ك متر
من اقرب تجمع بشري كان عدد سكانه 100 نسمه
فقط في المغرب يبلغ عدد سكان اقليم الحوز
مركز الزلزال نحو 600 ال000 نسمه وهو زاخر
بالمدن والقرى وقريب من مراكش احدى كبرى
الحواضر المغربيه يلعب توقيت وقوع الزلزال
دورا ايضا في ارتفاع حصيله الضحايا او
انخفاضها وقوع زلزال المغرب وعيد الحاديه
عش مساء ربما ساعد كثيرين على النجاه
بخلاف زلازل مدمره اخرى تقع عند الفجر وسط
نوم لسكان كزلزال تركيا قبل اشهر للتوقيت
بعد اخر يرتبط بفصول السنه فقد يساعد
اعتدال الطقص كثيرا فرق الانقاذ بمعداتهم
على الاصول بسرعه وكفاءه للعالقين تحت
الانقاض بجانب موقع الزلزال وتوقيته يسلط
الضوء على طبيعه الارض التي يضربها
فالبيوت المبنيه على تربه رسوبيه لينه
اكثر تعرضا لضرر الهزات الارضيه العنيفه
وارتداداتها المتوقعه هذه المشا الماساويه
من اقليم الحوز بالمغرب ربما لم تكن اسوا
بفعل الطبيعه الصخريه القويه التي امتدت
عليها عشرات القرى المنكوبه مقابل ان نفس
تلك الطبيعه تصعب عمليات الانقاذ وتلك
البيوت بسيطه البناء قليله الطوابق قد
يرجى معها تحجيم الحصيله النهائيه للكارثه
فزلا كما يقول خبرائها لا تقتل الناس بل
تقتلهم المباني
المتهاوي